hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge trouble in mein will ihr merkt
schon dass in zukunft beziehungsweise
zurzeit allgemein immer immer häufiger
probleme bekommt ganz einfach weil
pfizer stoppt bekomme ich immer noch
fragen von wegen ihrer man kommt der
motor show mit der dna derzeit im urlaub
das heißt da können wir nicht so ganz
gut aufnehmen
der ist allerdings jetzt also wenn ihr
dieses video seht ist wahrscheinlich
montag
und der ist also wir nehmen jetzt am
mittwoch auf oder am dienstag und dann
kommt am mittwoch oder am donnerstag
denke ich die da die nächste folge der
today show also dann habt ihr es wieder
und allgemein ist jetzt bei mir wieder
schulzeit lass ich mal schauen wie ich
das hinkriege mit videos produzieren etc
jetzt geht's los
die ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht mag
zusammen mit anderen zusammen mit prime
war das prime oder was vor ort ich weiß
nicht einer von den beiden diese
komische stone web da dies auch noch mal
total bescheuert also cathedral und
stone irgendwas dingsbums maps sind
nicht zu die schrecklichsten maps finde
ich dies gibt so aber hier weiß ich
immer so ein paar kästen sind
beziehungsweise krieg nein jetzt hab ich
habe die ich war noch ein stein schwert
dwd braunstein schwert
die gäste das auch schon weg wo waren
wir dann nochmal kisten
ich weiß gar nicht wo noch im blick ist
irgendwas ich gebe auch gar keinen
schweizer pass ein weil mich eh wieder
alle wahrscheinlich am anfang obwohl ich
habe mich nehme hdj dass meine kiste so
mal schauen jetzt verschreibt mich
tausend mal mutige trader
das heißt ich laufe erst mal weit vom
vom tester weg also was ich sagen wollte
in zukunft also
da habe ich eigentlich wollte nur sagen
dass ich erstmal in nächster zeit nicht
allzu viel aufnehmen kann
weil ich eine facharbeit schreiben muss
und verarbeitet werden alle von euch
wissen die selber aufs gymnasium gehen
bzw schon in der uni sind und mich dann
ihm wie trotzdem gucken er jedenfalls
ist es 16 seiten die man dann einfach
nur voll dritteln muss mit irgendeinem
thema und das ist einfach total
anstrengend und da werde ich mich dann
täglich mit beschäftigen
von daher denke ich mal dass ich dann
die meiste zeit meiner freizeit damit
verbringen werde das heißt ich habe da
nicht allzu viel zeit für videos und da
muss ich einfach schauen was ich dann
machen werde
ich habe mir schon überlegt ich entweder
aufnehmen werde und zwar wird das
wahrscheinlich in zukunft zu werden
darüber wo ich mich ganz kurz quatschen
das wird in zukunft wahrscheinlich so
werden dass ich hauptsächlich alle zwei
ich bin gerade ein bisschen komisch bzw
geplant weil ich nicht weiß wo ich jetzt
leute an greifen soll weil keiner so
wirklich außerhalb von der mep stetig
verfolgt einfach denen ich glaube denen
schaffe ich noch zu töten
das war jetzt gerade eine ganz ganz
blöde idee
ok und jetzt muss ich ganz ganz schnell
weg weil das war eine richtig gute sache
ist die dass ich wenig zeit finden wir
dann wahrscheinlich alle zwei drei tage
ein video produzieren werde
ganz einfach aus dem grund weil ja ich
halte wenig zeit habe deswegen werden
die videos allerdings die dann kommen
besser bearbeitet sein und
manja so4 tretter points
euro fest ich bin fertig zwei herzen ich
muss euch schnell weg das heißt alle
zwei drei tage mal so ein video und
daneben eine mod video aber dann auch
besser bearbeitet weil die sache ist die
dass habe ich schon mal erzählt wenn ich
aus der schule komme nachdem ich dann
irgendwie sieben stunden nach sieben
stunden wohl weder sonderlich setzte
auch mehr als sieben stunden er sagen
ich bin so jeden tag dann in der
schulzeit um 6 uhr zu hause dann hat man
keine kraft mehr was aufzunehmen aber
man hat bock halt noch sowas zu
bearbeiten sage ich mal
und dafür findet man immer irgendwie
zeit das heißt dass ich dann
wahrscheinlich alle zwei bis drei tage
sollen wir machen werde
boah ist das ober- oder schüler dieser
typ ich musste jetzt irgendwie weg ich
muss mir keine sorgen
so kommt er kommt er kommt ja ich habe
triebfeder war das ein ganz schön gute
runde
ich habe immer noch zweiter points das
heißt man nochmal b 1 ich weiß es gibt
auch andere sachen im shop außer
krippenfeier
nur so nur ich hatte gerade keine zeit
zu gucken
ich bin total einfach ganz egal
ordentlich leute gequält ich glaube
viele leute oder fünf leute war eine
ganz gute runde und ja also ich denke
einfach mal eine runde hinter 300 das
weiß natürlich eine scheiß rund um
irgendwas zu labern welche die ganze
zeit abgelenkt war das tut mir leid aber
also in nächster zeit wirklich weniger
videos aber dafür so alle zwei drei tage
mal dann so trouble meilen will oder
irgendwie sowas kommt darauf an wie viel
zeit ich finden werde nur es ist halt
immer so die sache weil während der
schulzeit ihm was aufzunehmen das ist
total doof einfach nur vielleicht lasse
ich mir da noch irgendwas einfallen
naja werdet ihr auf jeden fall sehen
aber das wollte ich euch auf jeden fall
schon mal sagen und dann sehen wir uns
in der runde die ich jetzt an hängen
werde wieder so und da bin ich wieder
erweckt auf irgendwas es dauert noch 16
sekunden ist er ohne losgeht deswegen
muss ich mich ein bisschen
ich hab mal wieder meine normen geändert
irgendwie scheint trotzdem an den start
und kam nicht
aber es ist mein ziel und mein will es
eigentlich meine lieblings map weil ich
hier immer genau den passenden weg ab wo
man immer kisten kriegt man wirklich bei
allgemeinem akten sind hier hier dann
noch hier
und zack so alles gut
klasse so dann werde ich versuchen zu
ändert es zu kommen ich werde
wahrscheinlich eh nix kriegen weil
ändert es das immer so ein bisschen
naja ich hab nie glück für die gäste
übrigens wenn die ideen hab mir grad
schon gesehen ideen habt bezüglich
projekte dann könnt ihr mir das einfach
in die kommentare schreiben
auf jeden fall auch ganz neues wer ganz
neues wenn ihr mir da so ein bisschen
bescheid geben könnte etwas ihr sehen
wollt ich habe da zwar schon eine gute
idee die ich machen könnte aber die wird
dann halten alle drei vier tage kommen
ähnlich wie die mythen schaut ihr euch
alle mal wieder gewinn schreibt
allerdings fand ich die nicht sogar ein
und wird deswegen wahrscheinlich wort
anderes machen aber ich hab's nicht na
toll
so natürlich erst mal so als welche auch
einer von denen
und häufig hier rum und zusätzlich den
festtagen werde aber wahrscheinlich
werde allgemein in zukunft mein bett
reglemente mach das ja immer so dass ich
ein bisschen vorsichtig bin laden
zwar offensiver vorgehen
das heißt mehr leute schlagen mehr leute
an greifen und nicht so von wegen
ihr könnte mich im hintertreffen nicht
so nach dem motto sondern schon so ein
bisschen aggressiver sage ich mir okay
ich habe einen trader point ich brauche
zwei dann habe ich über file und dann
mache ich ordentlich terror im test das
heißt eine person noch töten
entschuldigung entschuldigung schmidt
gern london töten sei gar keiner mehr
leben aber noch relativ viel ich weiß
nicht wie viele leute so ungefähr trader
23 45 66 sind reiter und zwei detectives
okay wir sind eine menge leute gerade da
hinten ist ein trader dem laufen einfach
hinterher den 30 mal einfach an so ich
habe das gefühl dass eine menge leute
hinter mir sind weil dafür eine menge
leute nehmen nur eine zb 1 so
hey wieso kann ich ihn nicht schlagen
war doch jetzt ja mach ich klar ich
verschont ich jetzt weil du mir rechte
dingsda zeigt wenn zwei leute auf dich
drauf kino.to kann nicht sterben tue ich
nicht
fakt dass falls natürlich ein eigentor
mehr oder minder so egal ich habe 16 5
watt immer genauer heft 5 trader points
vier top 12 trader points davon
allerdings kaufte eine menge leute
getötet
manche wieder eine geile runde na ja
danke fürs zu schauen erst mal ich
wünsche euch allen noch ein
wunderschönes schulzeit in nächster zeit
ich hab ja schon in sechs wochen
schulferien und ich wollte mich
allgemein mal dafür bedanken dass er in
den ferien so aktiv war nicht so aktiv
weiter empfohlen habe ich habe eine
menge abonnenten dazu gemacht wir sind
nun glaube ich schon bei über 70.000
oder ich wie ich habe überhaupt keinen
plan wie viele das mittlerweile sind ich
konnte hinterher
danke auch erst mal dafür dass er den
die parodie so gut angenommen habe dafür
dass die erste parodie wir haben schon
zweite parodie mit war langweilig habe
schon text geschrieben und ich hab schon
song ausgesucht die sie die wird sowas
von viel geiler werden
und naja programm gewonnen server wird
jetzt beendet da super feuerwerk ja
meine lieben freunde wenn ihr immer noch
dran seid könnt ihr mal einfach trader
in die kommentare schreiben
dann sehe ich wie viele bis zum ende
geschaut haben videos als eva bei ich
würde ich meine positive bewertung
freuen
und ja wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal